if this story
were not a tragedy of ignorance among
our elected leaders
it would be the stuff of comedy legend
but sadly
it's not because it's so serious what am
i talking about well
democrats now support a 15 an hour
minimum wage nationally
republican senator from south dakota
john thune
opposes a 15 minimum wage
and he tweeted that 15 an hour is just
too much
and his evidence is that back when he
was a youngster
he only earned six dollars per hour
tweeting quote i started working by
bussing
tables at the star family restaurant for
a dollar an hour
and slowly moved up to cook the big
leagues for a kid
like me to earn six dollars an hour
businesses in small towns
survive on narrow margins mandating a
fifteen dollar minimum wage
would put many of them out of business
now john thune
is of course either forgetting or
ignoring something called
inflation for a moment forget about a
productivity adjusted minimum wage
forget about a cost of living adjusted
minimum wage
let's just deal with inflation john
thune is 60 years old
he said when i was a kid let's say that
it was when he was 18 years old i i
my guess is we don't know what year this
was but we'll say he wasn't 14 he wasn't
16. let's assume he was actually already
18 years old when he was talking about
this
when he was working at the star family
restaurant that would put it at 1979
or more than 40 years ago
merely adjusting for inflation six
dollars per hour
in 1979 would be 21.62 cents per hour
today
and he's opposed to a 15
minimum wage based on what he earned
in the late 1970s is this some kind of
bad
joke i mean like tell me this is a bad
dream and he's not really
this ignorant and maybe he's not maybe
he's doing this because he knows
it's his followers that are actually the
ignorant ones now
i will be the first to admit i've
conceded before i've talked about this
before
there are legitimate questions that can
be brought up
about a 15 minimum wage in some places
for example
in a state like alabama which has no
state minimum wage meaning the
prevailing minimum wage there
is the federal one of 7.25 an hour
alabama
has a 7.25 an hour minimum wage cost of
living
is really low it's one of the lowest in
the country there is a legitimate
question to think about if you more than
double the minimum wage
in alabama where cost of living is so
much lower than in many other parts of
the country
what does happen to a primarily to a
service-based business where labor is
the primary input now
again i'm not talking about mcdonald's
where
labor is not the primary input but
rather it's
rent of the facility supplies
the food i'm talking about like really a
service-based small business in alabama
where they have to double
more than double whatever every employee
is making we can talk about that
i think that's a perfectly reasonable
thing to discuss
but john thune's argument i made six
dollars an hour in 1979
so 15 is too much today even though six
back then
is more than 21 in today's dollars
that's a non-thinking argument
he's making a great argument for a large
increase to the minimum wage
he made six dollars an hour 40 years ago
the federal minimum wage
is only 7.25 right now and it's 40 years
later
if there is ever a better argument that
the minimum wage is too low
it's that 40 years ago he made six and
now it's only 7.25
now the more likely scenario
is that john thune does understand this
and that ignoring inflation
makes his argument ridiculous but he's
putting out an argument that his
republican followers will fall for
merely to so doubt which is how these
propaganda battles
are won and lost get people to hear that
talking point
over and over and over again and repeat
it even if it's obviously ridiculous
another popular one
for the anti-minimum wage people is
listen if more money is good why stop at
fifteen dollars an hour make it fifty
or a hundred or a thousand dollars an
hour give everybody a thousand dollars
an hour
and then everybody will be rich and of
course that ignores
that calculating what the minimum wage
should be is not just a calculation of
what would you like to earn oh you want
to make 500 grand a year great yeah
let's figure that out
no you have to have a minimum wage that
in context
is an equilibrium wage adjusted for
inflation
cost of living productivity etc
and there is no mathematical argument
there's no economic argument you could
make
for a hundred dollar an hour minimum
wage i've not heard anyone
advocate for that so we'll have more
about this my question which you can
answer find us on instagram at
davidpakmanshow and you can answer there
do you think john thune is this stupid
or do you think
he knows about inflation and just
assumes his followers are that stupid
that they'll
fall for this follow us on instagram at
david pakman show
the more we learn about various diets
around the world
the more we realize that some of the
healthiest diets where folks are living
the healthiest and the longest
are heavily plant-based and one of our
sponsors
just egg is a great place to start just
egg
cooks and tastes just like real eggs
but it's made from plants it has less
saturated fat
no cholesterol packed with protein i've
been cooking with just egg at home
and you can use it in so many different
ways
just like traditional eggs omelets
scrambled eggs french toast
banana bread one of my favorite dishes
pad thai
it also is better for the planet
generating 93
fewer carbon emissions and 98 percent
less
water than conventional eggs you can
find just egg at lots of grocery stores
whole foods kroger amazon prime now
and instacart check it out just egg
really is a great product from a company
with a great
mission and i'm really glad that they're
a sponsor of the show